The joe rogan experience.
Nothing destroys bullshit like marijuana
and when someone's bullshit and your
high like,
oh,
come on man,
don't even say that.
Right to stop.
Like it's so obvious.
This is not true.
This is not a true thing.
It's a lay man.
Is that,
Oh God,
it's everywhere.
There's a number of honorary miss and
telling me two plus two is 18 I'm like,
what the fuck are you?
Stop making all this noise cytology 10
about people in la that already aren't
used to being told no,
you're wrong.
What you're saying is
just worship hauled on it.
Right.
You know,
or how about this,
you're lying.
Stop lying.
It's a little bit of that going on.
Oh my God,
it's unbelievable.
You know,
one of the things I
was saying to a friend,
we're talking about one thing that
I don't like about people that are
struggling,
especially struggling as actors,
it's the arena that they're
forced to compete in the arena.
They're forced to compete is an arena
where they're constantly going to
auditions where there's this weird
social thing going on where there's one
person who's in control,
the casting director and is a director
who's observing you and your whole thing
is about getting these people to like
you quickly in a brief amount of time.
And so they adopt like really obvious
democratic left wing sort of tendencies
and things to say and they adopt,
you know,
a very left wing mindset because that's
the majority of the people in Hollywood
are the left wing and they start spewing
out shit that they think people want to
hear as opposed to having a real
thoughtful opinion on something that's,
that's a very good point.
Very few people have the luxury of
having a real thoughtful opinion.
It's all about getting
someone to like you.
into the door and it's so,
so true,
man.
Terrible weight of thinking
about that the other day.
That is so true.
That becomes this,
this way.
You have to,
you have,
you're bullied into
speaking a certain way.
Cause if you don't,
you're going to be considered
a shithead or you know,
not on the team man.
You don't know the tone of the team and,
and you see it all the time.
Well the left wing aspect of it is
kills ideas.
Jimmy Schubert,
I forget what he calls her love.
She calls herself a,
you know,
a liberal conservative or whatever
because he wants to work in show
each human.
He could never go to an audition
with a Mitt Romney shirt on.
There was not a single fucking
person would ever hire you.
That's something that they would really,
it would prejudge you for sure.
Let me go get this Guy Outta here.
That is a hard game though.
Acting man.
I know there was a,
when I lived in that
building and Korea town,
there was a actor guy
that lived in my building.
Uh,
you know,
it's starting to get up there in age for,
for an actor or whatever.
And I guess his was work kind of dried up.
And uh,
for some reason when I would see this guy,
he would tell me
everything about his life.
For some reason he thought we were,
you know,
whatever.
Great friends.
I told the guy very little about me,
he just would always just spew all
this information about himself.
And I remember him telling me,
cause it was a bar downstairs in that
building and him telling me one night the,
uh,
I'm getting out of show business story,
I loved the,
like you and I were talking about it,
never even considered stopping doing this.
But like,
so I,
it kills me when somebody gives,
I'm getting out of show business,
speech,
I've given my all
and then,
uh,
all the phone is,
he said the guy,
he,
you know,
cause nothing had gone on for men
and worked in a couple of years.
And then he got this
little roll on Deadwood,
like say I don't,
maybe one line or he,
you know,
he was on a horse or something.
And then like,
uh,
and you know,
that rejuvenated his spirit.
But I remember the guy telling me sometime
after that that this girl had dumped
him and he's just,
he's just incredulous.
He can't believe it happened.
And he just keeps saying to me,
but I was on deadwood and Whoa,
like who?
Who could dump me?
I was on this town allows you to
reinvent yourself and reinvent,
invent your own reality.
Man,
it's a crowded,
we not wanting to be involved
in life with someone who people,
people do that.
All the mud thing to say.
It was another time where there was a
little cafe on the corner and he was a,
it was like a sunny Sunday or something.
He was sitting in front of their reading,
the big Sunday newspaper and
he had the homes section.
He's looking through and I'm
just being a smart ass night.
Um,
you know,
I walk up to him,
I like,
oh,
your career must be doing really well.
Now if you're looking at the,
at the home section and he looks
up from his paper and he just goes,
no,
just daydreaming.
And you know what I'm going to do
one day when I can afford a house,
I'm going to build walls so high to
keep the shit in this city away from me.
Oh,
like the most venomous,
very high.
That anger.
I'm like,
it's a sunny Sunday.
Loosen up your talk.
You know what you don't so hard.
I got a great story.
This is Phil Walden.
Separate all this come from,
I knew a guy,
my acting class and you
know how long I was smacking
in class years.
I loved it by the way,
for a lot of reasons.
Mainly because it was
just fun to be in just,
there was a lot of craziness and
Joe would always make fun of me.
But there was a guy,
really good guy,
normal guy.
So I thought and he was,
and I hired him to shoot
me to shoot this audition.
So I go to his house and he's got this
great camera and on his wall is a dream
board and on his wall is
his,
no,
no.
He's put his face,
he's put his face on the cover of
vanity fair and those magazines,
he's got slogan's saying you're the guy,
you're the one and it's a dream board.
And it was big.
It was good.
Covered his whole wall man.
And he's a good guy and he's like,
he's a normal guy.
And a lot of ways he's just been
told the wrong things is Jay Davis.
No,
it is not cheap.
I love,
that's almost like,
you know,
go to a girl's house and she's got
too many stuffed animals on the bed.
That's like the male equivalent.
He thought he showed me so much to him
even though he was trying to visualize
his future and it never,
I,
I've never gone,
oh,
it's never gonna happen Bro.
Say Jay Davis,
Jj was very nice.
He's a great guy
to Jay.
So enthusiastic board.
Yeah.
Is just an enthusiastic guy
who's just loves everybody.
But,
but uh,
this guy handsome,
tall,
you know,
suave and just like,
you're a Dork,
bro.
I got to help you take
that down right now.
See his picture,
his face over celebrities faces on
Vanity Fair and people magazine.
I'm not kidding.
He can visualize himself doing that.
Dane cook a big,
well,
I don't know.
Chose,
stop bringing behaves it.
You're going to run into that guy and
he's not going to have made it and he's
going to go,
you're the reason I'm not getting,
or
he's a good guy.
The best warm.
I love the guy actually.
He's a great guy.
It's just nuts.
He was told what happens sometimes is
people are told something enough times and
they forget to stop and think.
It's exactly what you're talking about
with the Fox thing is like who says you
can't swear and why are
you doing with somebody?
Why is it,
why are you doing with a court?
You forgot the idea of a podcast.
You have to keep thinking because you'll
make choices sometimes because you're
told that this works.
Yeah.
Who Shed it works.
I can't visualize running pumps back
in the NFL are fighting in the octagon.
Don't have it.
No matter what I do and can happen,
I'm getting fucking knocked out cause
my bone structure or for a thousand
reasons I don't have it.
Okay.
Tried,
didn't work.
So you know you've got to,
yes you should dream big,
but you should also be
realistic with who you are.
So when you say someone told him that
all you have to do is use the power of
positive thing.
Correct.
Use the ideal age thinking
the law of attraction,
all that shit.
And what happens when you read books
about it and it's written enough.
You seen a book's written,
you start to go,
this must be this.
This is a truth.
Okay.